now the people of chile head to the
polls this weekend to decide
who will create a new constitution
the existing framework dates back
decades to the autocratic rule
of general augusto pinochet while mass
protests
helped spur a referendum that set out
the makeup of the assembly half of the
new delegates
have to be women the draft constitution
will be voted on
next year a few months ago ivana miranda
never would have imagined she be running
for office now she's on the campaign
trail
as a candidate for chile's
constitutional assembly
miranda wants to help write the new
constitution
the current one dates back to the
pinochet dictatorship
the new constitution should be written
by ordinary citizens
because we know the real life
circumstances in chile
and we know that so far the state
doesn't guarantee us the rights we
should have
in 2019 after weeks of police violence
and riots
the efforts of 1.5 million protesters
paid off
chile's citizens will now draft a new
constitution
miranda hopes to use this chance to
bring about change she's demanding that
groundwater be distributed fairly
in the dry region of salamanca where she
lives
until now farmers have pumped water from
100 meters below the ground
to supply their avocado plantations
how can it be possible that there is
enough water for hundreds of acres of
avocado monocultures
but not for local communities
in many places people depend on water
financed by taxpayers
but time and again these pipes are
closed off because water
is in short supply i have three children
so it's hard to get by with the water
rationed from the pipes
that's why we rely on the city's water
truck it comes by once a week
another truck is from a private company
that the neighborhood residents pay for
out of their own pockets
according to chile's current
constitution water is private property
miranda shows us a new pipe made by a
private water supplier
it was developed for the avocado farmers
not the residents
the current constitution favors
agriculture this pipeline starts at one
of the few remaining above ground
springs
and was originally intended to provide
water to locals
the fact that water is private property
has led to dried up rivers
next to lush green avocado plantations
exporters hoard their water in huge
basins
and expand their avocado groves every
year
the new constitution must finally right
the wrongs of capitalism
and distribute water fairly especially
during the current drought
and climate crisis
50 of the seats in the constitutional
assembly are reserved for women
that's why miranda has high hopes for
her campaign
social activists like me have to push
harder to get heard
it's important that we put pressure on
the old political elite
now the outcome of the vote will play a
key role in shaping chile's new
constitution
a lot at stake this weekend for chile
i'm now joined by my colleague
benjamin alvarez gruber thank you so
much for being here benjamin good to see
you
is this chile's moment of reinvention
it is it reinvention not just as a state
but also to find this new
framework agreement for the next 40 50
years
it's a way of channeling the social
interest that started in 2019 it's the
second part let's remember that there
are three votes
the first one was the referendum in
october where almost 80 percent of
chileans said that they want to scrap
the current constitution that dates back
to the dictatorship of aruso pinochet
and now this weekend they will elect the
155 members
they will have the very difficult task
of drafting this new constitution
very difficult task what's exactly at
stake
what's very important to note here is
that the difficult
challenge starts now for the outside for
the
for the other countries it's interesting
to see how many women are involved we
just heard about it
half of them will be women there will
also be extra seats for the indigenous
population
there are several topics that should be
also in this new constitution
when it comes to changing the current
model and that for one
for some part of the people have started
and have helped chile to grow over these
last
30 years but on the other side people
are saying that this constitution has
also
fathered the social injustices in the
country that's why people went out to
the street and protested
now obviously i mean as you know chile
is often referred as the
south america star but underneath the
surface
there is a lot that uh needs addressing
there is a lot there even the current
president severity pinera once said that
chile is the oasis of the region
he said that before the social unrest
and you can see when you look under the
surface
those are a lot of things that cannot be
seen when you only look at macroeconomic
numbers for example
the inequality the poverty a lot of
people that need to go out now you see
it during the pandemic that they just
couldn't stay
at home that needed to go out and see
how they can get money
to the family and even the former health
minister said that he wasn't aware of
the level of poverty
that a lot of people in the country were
living in so i think
this changed also the look of chile in
other countries and i'd say the chile
has had a pretty good
marketing to sell itself as a developing
country and in conclusion uh benjamin
the pandemic of course hanging like a
dark cloud over
uh chile because it was initially doing
well how is the country faring right now
that's right chile was hit pretty hard
by the pandemic
and chile is seen as an example outside
so on one side it's been praised
internationally
for its amazing and pretty incredible
vaccine rollout but on the other side
also as a warning sign
for other countries to what happens when
you lift restrictions too quick
so don't wait for the effect of the
vaccine and this
vote had to be moved this election had
to be moved to the pandemic
but for now of course people hope that
the situation will get better and
cases will go down all right thank you
so very much benjamin alvarez
gruber from our very own dw news thank
you appreciate you thank you
you